[Musique]
nathalie qui pend dédié à 54 ans très
jeune elle perd ses parents aient grandi
à saint pol entouré de ses frères et
soeurs musiciens qui accueillait
beaucoup d'artistes à la maison alors
qu'elle est en activité dans le domaine
social
elle participe en tant que bénévoles à
l'organisation de la grande
manifestation culturelle karba réunion
en 1996 et 1997
c'est dans ce contexte qu'elle rejoint
le groupe disque à caen comme manager de
1996 à 1998 elle organisera des tournées
internationales pour le groupe
de 1997 à 2005 elle intègre l'équipe du
séchoir en qualité des programmatrices
musique et danse où elle met en place
plusieurs événements comme le saint leu
dans ce festival
le battle hip hop de saint leu et le
festival sakifo
en 2005 elle et programmatrice est
chargée de production du festival de
danse de saint denis
elle deviendra ensuite chargé de la
programmation du kabardock au port la
qualité et la diversité de ses choix
artistiques feront le succès de cette
salle de spectacle la qualité de
l'accueil qu'elle réserve aux artistes
depuis plus de 20 ans a fait la
réputation de nathalie qui pend dédié
dans les plus importantes sociétés de
productions françaises et étrangères
en 2008 elle devient membre du jury
faire et depuis 2015
elle est membre du comité d'experts
musique et danse de l'adac auj
parmi les plus grands artistes musiciens
qu'elle a accueilli à la réunion au
kabardock ou dans le cadre du festival
opus pocus
on peut citer gilberto gil cesaria evora
marcus miller
nathalie qui pend dédié s'est ainsi
construit un vaste réseau professionnel
particulièrement dans les domaines du
jazz et des musiques du monde
elle est sans doute la seule
programmatrice de lille a disposé d'un
tel réseau avec la crise du coc u19
nathalie n'a pas ménagé ses efforts pour
finaliser ces programmes est adapté
selon les possibilités de la conjoncture
anne accueille limiter notamment les
après midi des week-ends ce qui fait
qu'elle ne connaît pas de répit
loin d'abandonner cette avec résilience
et volonté qu'elles se projettent dans
un retour à la normale pour faire de sa
programmation une offre de qualité
reconnu par tous
[Musique]